wie bitte sind menschen für den
chinesischen ausbruch des corona virus
verantwortlich in den sozialen medien
kursieren quellen denen zu folgen das
virus vor jahren in laboren hergestellt
wurde und es sich nun um eine gewollte
pandemie handelt wort krieg zum science
fiction hier gibt's täglich spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen kurzes update die infizierten
zahlen steigen unaufhörlich jetzt sind
offiziell schon 4.500 nach gestern 3000
menschen infiziert und mehr als 100 sind
gestorben inzwischen gibt es auch einen
infizierten in deutschland fachleute
fragen sich ob die pandemie noch
aufzuhalten ist und auch in den sozialen
medien ist das mysteriöse virus mit der
vorläufigen bezeichnung 2009/10 ncv
thema nummer eins hier wird angezweifelt
ob die etablierten medien wirklich mit
allen informationen herausrücken egal ob
er instagram twitter whatsapp oder
youtube überall gibt es informationen zu
dem virus und zwar mit quellen belegt
demnach unterliegen wir alle einer
riesigen täuschung denn die normalen
medien würden alle nicht darüber
berichten ein großes thema
beispielsweise die patentnummer des
corona virus sucht man mit google nach
kroner virus ist einer der vorschläge
patent und tatsächlich hat der korona
virus eine patentnummer und diese ist
auch öffentlich bei google patent
einsehbar wurde da tatsächlich ein
skandal aufgedeckt diesen quellen
zufolge wurde das virus bereits vor acht
jahren in laboren hergestellt jetzt hat
er sich ausgebreitet und dabei andere
sich um nichts anderes als um eine
gewollte potenzielle pandemie demnach
hat das virus also jemand erfunden und
patentiert in manchen post ist auch die
rede davon dass die us regierung hinter
dem virus steckt um mehr menschen zu
einer impfung zu zwingen leider muss ich
mal wieder die verschwörungstheoretiker
enttäuschen es gibt nicht den einen
corona virus es handelt sich um eine
ganze viren familie und ja es gibt
patente mehrere sogar dabei handelt es
sich um abgeschwächte version des corona
virus die patentiert wurden diese
patente sind enorm wichtig für die
entwicklung potenzieller impfstoffe das
immunsystem soll so auf diese art von
viren trainiert werden um im worst case
auch gegen sie vorgehen zu können
mich zu impfen manchen theorien zufolge
gibt es sogar schon eine impfung die uns
aber vorenthalten wird fakt ist hier
labore weltweit arbeiten mit hochdruck
daran eine abgeschwächte version des
virus zu entwickeln die sich für
impfungen eignen könnte die große
herausforderung dabei diese virus
version darf weder zu stark noch zu
schwach sein denn ansonsten taucht die
impfung nichts bzw
die geimpften könnten erkranken die
behauptung dass das neuartige corona
virus im labor hergestellt wurde und
dies mit dem patent bei google belegt
werde ist kompletter umbruch wie gesagt
es gibt nicht den einen corner virus
sondern es handelt sich um eine riesige
familie zudem werden impfungen noch
entwickelt patente auf die anderen
abgeschwächten form von corona wären
sind nicht auf die neue version die sich
gerade ausbreitet anzuwenden es handelt
sich also eindeutig um
verschwörungstheorien die zu angst und
panik führen könnten allerdings könnte
der mensch tatsächlich für die
entstehung verantwortlich sein
der us wissenschaftler peter rabinowitz
vermutet nämlich in einem interview mit
news dass es sich um eine vermischung
von schlangen und fledermaus wären
handeln könnte möglich sein dass wenn
beide tierarten auf märkten wie dem im
buch sehr eng beieinander gehalten
werden das würde dann also doch bedeuten
dass der mensch in gewisser art und
weise selbst verantwortlich für die
erschaffung des virus ist der
möglicherweise hat die erkrankung die
durch das neue corona virus ausgelöst
wird ihren ursprung eben auf einem markt
in dura chinesischen gesundheitsbehörden
und auch die weltgesundheitsorganisation
gehen derzeit davon aus ähnlich wie das
sars virus damals ist das kroner virus
wohl von infizierten tieren auf menschen
übergegangen auf dem markt in hand waren
es wohl höchstwahrscheinlich infizierte
schlangen wie ein pekinger
forschungsteam herausgefunden haben will
beide schlangenarten sind im südosten
chinas häufig darunter auch in der stadt
woran viele patienten haben im markt
verloren gearbeitet wird diese schlangen
verkauft wurden
laut der aktuellen studie hat eine
veränderung an einem oberflächenprotein
dazu beigetragen dass der sprung über
die art barriere zum menschen gelungen
ist konkret geht es um die chinesische
cobra und den sogenannten feel
gebänderten kreuth die pekinger
fachleute hatten das genom von 5
oben 2009 10 n tv mit 217 ähnlichen
viren verglichen die zuvor aus
zahlreichen tierarten entnommen wurden
diese analyse zufolge zeigt sich das
neue virus sehr ähnlich zu wehren die
bereits in fledermäusen gefunden worden
und das spricht wieder für den fatalen
übergang von den fledermäusen auf die
schlange das chinesische forschungsteam
sieht jedenfalls die schlangen als wirte
von denen die erreger aus auf den
menschen übergesprungen sind andere
fachleute sehen das skeptisch und halten
es für wahrscheinlich dass doch
fledermäuse die natürlichen wirtin des
hcv sind so oder so zeigt sich mal
wieder dass wildtiere am besten nicht
verkauft und zubereitet werden denn bei
diesem kontakt können ganz schnell der
pandemien entstehen wie sich jetzt
leider eben beeindruckend zeigt und was
noch wichtig ist bei einem solch ernsten
thema ist es wichtig sich bei seriösen
quellen schlau zu machen und zu
informieren und auch klar zu sagen wenn
etwas nicht klar ist und nicht zu
verschweigen und nichts dazu zu erfinden
denn falsche informationen sind in einer
krisensituation alles andere als
hilfreich und können am ende panik
auslösen
damit euch informieren können wir haben
eine playlist mit all unseren videos zum
corona virus gemacht hier drauf
anklicken anschauen und natürlich klicks
um science-fiction abonnieren dann
verpasst er nichts ach so ja
bis dann bleibt dran